quand le messie arrivera rome ne sera
plus rien en attendant le nazaréen a
affirmé qu'il allait susciterait au bout
de trois jours si c'est vrai que c'en
sera fini de l'ordre et de la paix les
gens à valros couleuvres en les sables
d'esprit sans doute il n'y aura pas
d'autre dieu traîné
e
le tombeau est scellé gardez le
farouchement riba pilates demande
le corps se volatiliser le tombeau
évident utile à toi me le dire il
raconte déjà partout que l'homme est
revenu d'entre les morts
l'empereur ne peut pas arriver au milieu
du chaos
nous devons trouver ce corps à tout prix
retrouvent tous ceux qui sont morts la
semaine dernière je les sors de la force
je les veux tous les disciples ou
cache-t-il son cadavre
ce n'est pas l'oeuvre des fidèles de
jésus
on vient de trouver un corps
non
qui t'a dit que le nazaréen étaient en
vie marie madeleine tu ne trouveras
jamais ce que tu cherches tribun ouvre
ton coeur et regarde arrête de mentir
comment ont-ils réussi à l'emporter les
cordes am explosé on devrait être revenu
à présent
j'ai été témoin d'une chose qu'ils ne
pourraient jamais se concevoir
un homme mort sous mes yeux
et ce même homme
à nouveau envie
qu'est ce qui te ferait me tromper et
miser l'éternité là dessus